Welcome to Aera English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Now in the past, I've had some guests in my own show like Imran...
...and today, I have a new guest.
This is Ikuyo.
Hi, Seita!
Hey! Can you help these guys become a native maestro?
Sure!
Alright, thanks a lot!
Thanks, Seita!
Hi! This is Ikuyo.
So, today's Maestro Hook.
If your English is not so good and if you're lost for words while you are talking,...
...there is a good way to keep a steady pace.
And put words like, "well" or, "let's see" or, "let me think".
So, these words help you keep a steady pace,...
...so please use them.
So, today's Maestro Menu.
I got plans.
I'm busy.
I got a plan.
It's not for me.
No, thank you.
So, Maestro Lines.
Seita, can you help me?
Yup. Use these sentences?
Yup, sure.
Okay. Ikuyo, we have a business meeting at 8 o'clock.
Can you make it?
Oh, well 8 o'clock. Sorry, I got plans.
Oh, you got plans?
Yeah, I can't make it.
Okay.
I'm sorry about it.
No problem.
So, like this.
So, the next one.
Okay, in a...
Oh! So yeah, at a clothing job.
Oh, miss! Do you like this shirt?
What do you think?
Oh, well I'm sorry it's not for me.
No? You don't like it?
Not really. I'm sorry about it.
Thank you, no problem.
Okay, like that.
Yup.
So, I think that's it...
...and I hope you enjoyed it.
So, see you later.
Thank you. Bye-bye!